[Music]
hey guys
it's katie i'm chris and we are not in
the kitchen no we're in the great
outdoors today we're going to teach you
guys some of our favorite camping
recipes and tricks and tips along the
way delicious camping food and rizzo's
gonna be eating anything that falls on
the ground she's not gonna help us
she's poop this is the content
you need
this first recipe is a spicy queso dip i
love this because it's perfect for after
a hike or while you're playing cards at
the campsite and you can throw it
together in no time you'll prep chorizo
at home and because it's super greasy
you're going to want to drain that on a
paper towel i like to use a
compartmentalized lunchbox to store my
recipe ingredients that way everything's
together when i get to the campsite and
it's easy to throw in the pan
for this recipe i'm using an 8 inch cast
iron skillet so you can either cook it
over the fire or on a propane stove this
queso gets its spice from the pepper
jack cheese chorizo and jalapeno cook it
for about three minutes stir it together
and you have got queso in less than five
minutes i like to serve this with chips
but also some vegetables this way you
know we're kind of balancing out all
that cheese for garnish we'll add slices
of jalapeno and a little cilantro and
that's my easy spicy queso should i give
it a go yes do it i'm gonna do a red oh
here we go
reactions thoughts
explosions in my mouth happiness
my whole life flashing before my eyes i
would say that that is
the best thing i've ever eaten
for dinner i am making a giant
crunchwrap this was inspired by a
camping trip i took with my friends
where we all made personal quesadillas
and my love for taco bell this is super
fun to make it's huge it's impressive
and it cooks really well over a campfire
to get started you're going to make your
beef filling at home once that's cooked
and no longer pink add your taco
seasoning and a little lime juice you
also can really customize this dish if
you want to make it vegetarian or you
could do chicken fajitas you can really
tailor it for your needs i'm going to
throw these in a takeout container i
like to save these because they work
great as tupperware and they're also
free when you're putting this together
at the campsite make sure you spray your
cast iron pan this will ensure that the
crunchwrap does not get stuck to the
bottom and flips nicely later on then
we're going to add in our ingredients
layer by layer i love this recipe
because the prep is easy and it's really
quick to throw together i know when i'm
camping i don't want to spend my whole
time cooking i want to be playing games
and just enjoying being outside for the
crunch just grab some of the chips you
were serving with your queso and crush
those all over the top you can use
whatever kind of chips here you want top
that with some iceberg lettuce and then
i like to put my sour cream in an old
condiment squeeze bottle i find this
easier to put on your crunchwrap than
scooping it out of a container last
you'll top that with tomatoes and one
large tortilla fold that on all the
sides this part can be a little tricky
doesn't have to look amazing and now
it's time to go on the fire we made a
log cabin style fire because it
distributes the heat more evenly and i
find it easier to tend to make sure your
fire has burned long enough that you
have hot coals to cook over place the
country up over the fire and let it cook
for 18 to 20 minutes until the bottom is
golden brown
the next part's a little tricky i like
to use a plate and spatula to help me
flip the crunch wrap and slide it back
into the pan and if it doesn't go right
back into the pan just use another
spatula and kind of wiggle it back in
there it'll be fine and you'll cook that
for another five to seven minutes until
the bottom is golden brown to serve this
i like to take a giant cutting board and
flip over the cast iron pan make sure
you're using oven mitts and gloves
because the pan is super hot one of my
favorite things i own are these knives
with covers they're perfect to take
camping and safe to travel with and
there it is your giant crunchwrap it's
epic it has amazing layers and it tastes
delicious oh my god oh my god
you know what i like about this the
tomatoes are still cool inside and the
sour cream is still cool but it still
has this nice crunch and the meat is
like nice and hot so you're saying that
i am a genius the best yes yes you are
oh thank you
for dessert we're making s'mores cones i
love these because you basically get to
make a dessert bar and everyone can
customize their s'more and you can
really use whatever toppings you like
we're using sprinkles and peanut butter
cups and chocolate chips whatever
deliciousness you want to throw in that
cone go for it the world's your oyster
just don't use oysters just be careful
when you're wrapping these because they
can break easily i got a little too
excited and definitely broke one they
still taste good broken but they're a
lot messier you can set these near the
coals of the fire or on the grate and
let them cook for about seven to ten
minutes or until the inside is at the
gooeyness level that you like
i'm about to eat a s'mores cone and
rizzo is those
she's super jealous
oh i really went for that
that's melty that's delicious
so good
it's delicious it's like s'mores but
mores
it's more s'mores
we're gonna party now till the sun goes
down
bye-bye
pro tip if you like to enjoy a cocktail
while you're camping buy pre-made ones
it's easy to pour over some ice and
store in a portable tumbler
[Music]
all right it's breakfast and you just
slept on the ground all night so i'm
pretty sure you want something easy and
delicious these cinnamon roll oranges
are to die for and easy to assemble use
a knife to cut around the flesh of the
orange just be careful not to cut
yourself and then take a spoon and scoop
it out my sister introduced me to this
recipe and i was a little skeptical at
first but after trying it the first time
and tasting the cinnamon roll infused
with the juices of the orange i was in
love so thank you kelly for teaching me
your ways make sure to save all the
orange slices because you can either eat
these or make fresh orange juice now
take your cinnamon rolls and pop that
container make sure to save the icing
because we're going to use that later
take your cinnamon rolls and place one
in each orange
place them in a cast iron pan and put
foil over the top make sure you leave a
little bit of room for the cinnamon
rolls to grow then place that over the
fire for about 35 to 45 minutes or until
golden brown it takes a while to cook
but that's going to give you plenty of
time if you're breaking down your tent
or if you're just waiting for those lazy
campers to wake up while the cinnamon
rolls are still hot take a knife and
spread the icing over the top and if you
feel like you want to be a little extra
you can use one of the leftover rinds
and grate it over the tops of the
cinnamon rolls this just gives it a nice
orange zest garnish and makes it a
little extra special it's breakfast time
whoa look at these are so cute oh these
are amazing cheers cheers
that's super good my favorite part about
this is just how they're infused with
the oranges it's delicious it tastes
like you're eating an orange made out of
cake
which is great and a little campfire
taste it's a little campfire yeah it's a
great way to start your morning yeah and
we also have some orange juice fresh
orange juice all right well that's all
from us thank you guys for watching
leave your tips and tricks in the
comments and if you try any of these
recipes tag me
and show us what you did try them
they're all super super super good
should we get rizzo to sign off um
[Music]
[Music]
you